their fallen hero
alexander tarakovsky the first of two
protesters to die
in a week of mutiny against disputed
elections
[Applause]
long live belarus they chant not backing
down
opposition leaders want dialogue with
the regime but the president instead
picking up the phone to russia's
vladimir putin
one of his main challenges is
disappointed he tried to
ask for help for putin and
it's we don't like it of course because
our
independent and uh superintendent of
belarus
is a main goal and we
we don't like to lose it only
because of president who want to stay as
a president here
yeah are you worried that that belarus
will become
kind of like a a football kicked between
russia and western europe
the european union the uk i'm worried
and i don't like this situation
i think we are independent and strong
enough
to make it by biblical russians not by
another countries the country has seen
protests at election time before
but nothing like this anger at a police
crackdown
prompting traditionally loyal state
workers to join in
an unprecedented challenge to the status
quo
nervous viewing two for russia's
strongman next door
lithuania though is a leading voice
backing the opposition
its president here has even said
alexander lisenka is no longer the
legitimate leader of belarus
but some other western allies are more
cautious they fear
go too strong against the government and
you just risk pushing the country even
closer
into russia's orbit for this belarus
watcher
doing too little would be worse the
momentum is now i believe belarusian
people that they can hold for
a day to maybe a week and
and that the energy they have is not
going to be
lost but they cannot stand in the
streets and
be creative for like four months
or years back in belarus signs of a more
tolerant approach to the protests
but this crisis remains highly volatile
debra haynes sky news vilnius